0-4.
SECOND AND FINAL IN HIS NHL CARR
BREAK-AWAY
NOW STUTZLE BACK INTO HIS END.
>> Bret: AGGRESSIVACT AS A GROU
PASS FROM BALCERS ON THE SECOND
OPPORTUNITY.
MURRAY WITH THE STOP.
>> Randy: TIM STUTZL THE GRAIN
TO GET AWA
AND HE DRILLEDDE
SHARKS' POWER PLAY IS 17 IN THE.
THEN YOU CAN SEE TIMO MEIER JUST
CROSSES IN FRONT REIMER.
CHABOT'S STILL GOT HE KNOWS WHE
IS OFF THE INSID
ROAD, STARTING IN CHICAGO.
GIVES OFF TO MEIER, TO HER WORKD
SHORTSIDE TOP CORNERERO THE
NET, TKACHUK THERE, HE DONE.
THIS IS -- TKACHUK, MAY HAVE
BEEN ABLWN, HE SCORES.
CONNOR BROWN, GUY YOU MENTIONED
BONINO AND HE SCORES TIMO MEIERO
BONINO RIGHT HERE IN FRONT,
FINDS THE NOW KARLSSON, TO THE E
L.
GETS SHOT, GOES THROUGH THAT
>> Bret: TIMO MEIE
KARLSSON, BONINO, JAKE MIDDLETON